oh no
i've never had mcdonald's before in my
whole life and i can't have this i told
myself i couldn't
[Applause]
hi i'm sabrina carpenter and this is
snack wars uk versus usa for lab bible
oh candy
yay
[Music]
okay
oh wow it's really good
straight in there
you had licorice before
yeah
it's not my favorite
these are not easy to open okay
oh
not the double packaging okay
interesting i've literally never heard
of this in my life
oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god
oh my god it's so sour oh my god it's so
sour
what
what the heck
oh my god that was crazy it like entered
my throat and just exploded i'm so
curious about these now i've never
exactly yeah
this is so interesting i have to try
another flavor
no
a good gym all right yeah
thank you so much no
wow
okay so like the whole thing
it's just been such a hard morning
so yeah i guess these just explode
after like five seconds in your mouth
just when you think it's over it's not
who's winning
i mean
neither deserve it but i would say this
because i'm so fascinated by it
oh
no
all right
hope you guys are ready
whiskey huh
okay
cheers
[Music]
no
[Laughter]
really bad
really really bad guys what are you
what are you thinking so bad wait
why does it burn
oh my god
oh my god i hated that
oh i gotta do this one okay
i hope this is better
no
give me a second give me a second i
can't you think they taste different
like is this a thing
i might throw up i might
okay
[Music]
god
awful
honestly i'm gonna say this one because
it wasn't but i did hold my nose but it
wasn't as
strongly
repulsive
as this one was blown off the teeth okay
oh
oh no
oh no
i've never had mcdonald's before in my
whole life and i can't have this i told
myself i couldn't i have like a very
specific goal that i have to reach
before i have mcdonald's yeah what is
the goal
it's like a personal goal
no
it's like once i once i do a certain
thing or like reach a certain thing then
i'll like go to celebrate it's like when
you win the super bowl and like
where are you going like i'm going to
disney world i'm going to mcdonald and
then this one
i've heard good things about this yeah
it's a
christmas bakery okay
oh um
so it's a sausage roll okay you guys
like this
yeah
[Music]
it's actually not that bad i don't know
why i was overreacting
it's pretty good
jerky
and then mr porky okay i'm gonna try
this one first
y'all have some weird taste
this smells so bad wait do i have to eat
that wait that smells terrible
what is this
guys
come on wait pork line
no why does it taste so bad
it's essentially fat yes
okay
let's try this one
this is pretty good it sucks
i've never had it before
i'm out of this this one though
no
i'm gonna give it to the usa
and whoever invented that
deserves
to be fired
[Music]
you okay i'm fine yeah i'm a little
drunk guys i'm sorry it's quite intense
a little tipsy
all right one two three
my god
woo